breaking news from ethiopia's amhara
region where reports say tigray rebels
have killed at least 125 people the
killings are said to have happened over
two days in a village near the town of
dabat last week tigran forces denied the
attacks calling it a fabricated
fabricated allegation
well samuel getachew is an independent
journalist he's joining us via skype now
from addis ababa thanks for being with
us uh so let me ask you first of all
what is your uh reading of this
development
well we've been speaking to the local
administration including
eyewitnesses they're confirming that at
least at least 125 people have died
which
almost all of them if not all of them
are amharas
but in the last hour the tplf
spokesperson guitar redact has come out
to say that
they're calling for some kind of
independent investigation uh and they're
denying that their soldiers really
committed what's being alleged at the
moment so i just [ __ ] us
just just to clarify for our viewers who
just explain to us who are the tplf
uh tplf uh a former um they ruled
ethiopia in a coalition which was
dominated by uh their forces
but they were their term ended in 2018
when the prime minister was selected to
lead some kind of change a revolution
that came from the people
and they've been since they've been
designated as a terrorist group
from adi sabhava and those are who they
are i mean malazanawi was the head of
the prime minister who was the head of
their government in ethiopia and they've
been at odds with the ethiopian
government since 2018. so how is the
current ethiopian government likely to
react to this then
well the ethiopian human rights
commission is said to be launching a new
investigation
the u.n
is continuing to show
disappointment uh in this ongoing
conflict that has affected thousands of
people
but the ethiopian side hasn't responded
they do respond on social media we've
been awaiting their response their
reaction since they haven't responded
but again uh people are dying the
conflict that began in november
continues to affect so many people
thousands of people that have died since
and this is the latest uh tragedy that
has uh been the result of it
uh and this latest development where
where does it fit into
uh the larger picture of what's been
happening uh in the tigray uh region and
beyond in ethiopia
the conflict that began within the
tigray region is no longer
within tegra it's going to the heart of
amhara this happened in china which is
an hour away from gundar the historic
city of gondar
and this goes to show you that the
conflict is not just it's not ending or
slowing down it's going to continue to
affect civilians
and it's everyday people that are being
affected uh but again
this conflict has been ongoing for since
november are faking so many people it's
approaching its first year in november
good to talk to you sam you'll get to
joining us there from addis ababa thank
you